citizens of the reject Nation it is time to
dive into my Adventures of Superman part 3
for us which is episodes 8 9 and the finale we
are going to be watching the finale in roughly
real time for the first time we caught up and we
are here John how you feeling I am so groovy koi
I wore my cryptozoology t-shirt in honor of my man
Jimmy Olsen I worked by Because the Internet shirt
because we're watching it on the internet yes
that's the correlation we're both uh thematically
appropriate yeah we're both going tangential
today also this Superman definitely a fan of
Donald Gluck oh definitely if he has any taste
this man knows his childish game being now and
speaking of taste you have taste for watching this
video and I'd like you to leave that taste in the
comment below and let us know what you want us to
dive into next let us know your taste your goals
your Acquisitions what you acquiesce what you
have been seeking for us to experience and hit
that like give us validation validate us with
your thumbs and your pointer fingers also hit
that subscription Bell and hit any other buttons
except the x that you want to hit is there still
an X in the screen they it's like a red circle
now might it's both and as ever the fine folks
at prepper are prepping they're prepping so
good they're prepping us for victory they're
prepping us to deliver this to you and they're
prepping a nice salad I imagine so thanks to
prepper for making us look nutritious and
smart we appreciate you and if you want
to watch us watch the entirety of this front
back beginning to end with our resting faces
then head on over to patreon to become a super
sexy reject where you can see this in its entire
tee without further Ado let's watch a part one
of two of my Avengers is Superman three two one
what's going on what it's a team up
and you're all on task force x I hope you like it
you destroyed property and endangered citizens oh
we find out who he is you will repay your debt to
society still thinking Lane I'm sticking with it
okay I'll stick with it I'm gonna go Deadshot
still I don't know why it's got a feeling I
think I think he's either Deadshot the one
is an old I mean you know he's not one he's
he's clearly in a position of power but he's
not as fit as he once was I'll take it I like
that I think it'd be interesting to have someone
that like is a different type but still working
with Waller I'm for it after this operation
Superman will cease to be a problem The General
huh It's gotta be overwhelming
cannot imagine Superman
Superman there was almost a bulldozer
accident I stopped it I have super
hearings this is so going on flamebird
manic Superman I can hear uh uh uh cat
and tree he has not slept I can
hear everyone Jimmy Jimmy Jimmy
you've been sleeping much buddy not for a few
days that's not important because I heard him
the general he's in the city and he's planning
something I can't stop until I find him damn
wow how did he get the omnipresent reigning
cherry pie flew out right as she came in
you put him in the ventilation of the entire
building oh that's cute oh what's excessive
I need you to assist Our Guest editorial right
Porter who broke the queen industry's
inheritance Scandal Who took down the
falcones Falcone name check and queen but she's
thinking of leaving the Gotham Gazette I want
her here winning us Awards I need you to
do whatever you can to keep her happy we
need her for more Batman Easter eggs we need
DC World expansion and Exposition and we're
writing about the number one greatest
danger to Metropolis Superman of course
on a crime spree downtown intergang The
Invisible Man he's the one the General's
looking for but he's invisible quite ironic
such a nice boy and he carries my groceries
flip Johnson yeah news kit and what is
your relationship to Superman he saved
Flip's life and he let Patty interview
him for the news kit newspaper people
sorry I don't have much time an invisible
man is running around and I think he's
connected to the general whoa bird watchers
say an invisible force broke the window at
Morrison's pawn shop less than a minute ago
whoa let's go meet my final interview subject
it's a general man's no hero he's the end
of the world have we met him is that isn't
that Alex Alex from the first Yeah Yeah
from the uh I think that's Lex oh boy
oh
mazotec and put thousands out of work I see
a level of Destruction no human could ever
achieve what about your boss if you really
wanted to hurt us what could we do about it
no just him having a bad day could spell
the end for us Batman metaphor yeah
it needs a little push you can't publish this
you want to be number one you don't get there by
writing fluff you go for blood that's something
fairy never understood yeah but you don't just
only go for blood she works on the internet I
mean you got one bad take and a bunch of you
know like do well on Twitter yeah you can't
fit Nuance into a headline we'll talk oh boy
whoa whoa heck you could have killed
someone no Invisible Man the worst day
for this right now I need to find the
general before well maybe you shouldn't
right now take a break from being Superman
and try being normal Spider-Man to this walk
away from the costume yeah put
it in a trash can ceremoniously
I need to save my sister they grabbed us after
you ruined our bank job I got away but they
got Siobhan and Albert they took him into an
underground facility with their other prisoners
they're moving everyone out today to some new
location if I don't break them out now I might
never find them again what Easter egg City are
they being moved to if you show me where they're
holding her I'll help you get them back damn
what a guy it's an interesting little plot line
oh cool Tech yeah we're too late no
we're not yeah not for me hold on
oh boss fight in the air no
I think you could ruin my life without any
consequences no self-awareness my guy no
but now he looks like a mix of like
Frieza and boo yeah I like this parasite
it's got a little bit of uh Gengar in
there too Pokemon all the animes yeah yeah
jeez We Can't Stop Clark but we can stop Vicky
we'll talk to Perry whoa did you
see what Vicki Vale just posted
oh boy
editor-in-chief she used us to get
promoted This is Gonna Hurt Clark
Lois this is gonna hurt Clark this is
hurting Clark right now bibo 87 was the name
bibo lives I hope we get yes oh I
hope this restaurant's doing well
nice grip on the physics too
no no
ah jeez
nice that was sick Jack Queen plus
this choreography this is like one
of my favorite Supermans yeah I love
this it feels like fresh but classic
yeah impressively yeah and he's got
that right every man kind of quality
I'm dead oh
God Stand Down Ivo they're gonna blow his head up
done when I say you're done either I'll tell
you when you've had enough why are you doing
this because you are no hero you are the end
of the world no I I I only want to shut him up
people keep saying that you wonder at the
end of the world it's very specific maybe
somebody with multiversal knowledge maybe it
wasn't all just fun and games with Mr mixy
really impressed with the pacing the overall style
like you said classic but new just impressive
stuff yeah and like again they're bite-sized
but they're also really nicely rounded they
work individually and as the Vicky Vale episode
but it's a part one of two it's got a whole Arc
we have the whole journey starting the next
one and we're back yeah anything on flame
bird nothing he disappeared off the face
of the Earth which is why we're here yes
the real heroes big words spot the walkie-talkies
Gabby made missing posters even even Patty is
helping Patty stepping up even Patty we'll find
him and everything will be okay you'll see MVP
of the Shelf yeah go stranger things kids find
that secret laboratory season two she's got mine
secretly that's Lucas's sister
she's credited D yeah
you're not going to punch your way out of this
one Superman now I need dates and numbers what I'm
lonely who's your black book yeah I've lived on
earth my whole life stop lying I was there on zero
day and so were you what an unidentified flying
object broke through the atmosphere but where are
you here taking a nap come on I'll be home soon I
can't believe you whoa uh Hey Mandy don't Mandy me
damn it is him get your head in the game you know
one day I'm not gonna be around to pull you out
of trouble what do you mean you've got a whole
series coming up in and out of continuity yeah
that's does not look like it means hope wild nope
is this like a Zod is this it looks Oddish yeah
whoa this definitely looks like their Tech yeah
yeah cool design work so the American government
retrofitting Kryptonian Tech that tracks
I like the motion blur and the edge
of frame stuff they're doing uh the
like lensing that they're putting on the
glassing effect that was intense yeah laughs
then you showed up passing yourself
off as a hero so you are going to
tell me everything you know who are
you and why are you on Earth who is
your dad dude what does he do scientist
you know I'm something of a scientist
Mrs Omega attacked and when it seems like we
finally have the answers in our grasp what if
we're wrong oh and if he's compromised your
commitment then it's time to get rid of him
we need information more than revenge we're
keeping Superman alive for questioning it's
my call not yours dismissed he'll
be following for long oh boy hey
still want to take down Superman
wow she hit you're kind of they're gonna need
Superman now yeah there you go these two to
deal with oh the only reason you won last time
is because you cheated you just hurt me I hurt
Wilson Waller Code Orange code oh
[__] Ivo stand down he's mine
yeah buddy
oh boy is that a freaking Kaiju
dammit inter gang and live wire and the rest of
them I like the stakes building up enough to make
a finale work for Superman yeah they do a good
job bye bye Black Ops no no agent slayed Wilson
I mean Ryden
that is how he will bond with Sam
's crazy that is a lot of parasite leave me
Clubhouse
remember when you asked me who I was
I'm a weapon I'm an alien Invader
sent to kill you all you're not a weapon
you're a person you'll never be Ultraman
this guy though oh damn it is a polask I do
like the centipede version of Godzilla whoa
it looks dinked yeah it does it looks very dank
very like very dank and moist and just yeah a
crab that sat out too a lot of mucus on him yeah
Clark you get him in your condition and he's just
getting stronger with every building he drains
and people are getting hurt Lois I have to try oh
is there a point where it just
explodes it would be nice if we
have fun subversion Superman shows
up just in time like Men in Black
oh yeah the heat vision come on I was gonna say
heat his energy but maybe this
energy doesn't feed him we have
why haven't I haven't go live Jimmy but my
real name is Jimmy Olsen play bird face reveal
reporter for the daily planets is under attack
Superman now defending US based Ivo people have
told you to fear super Superman because
he's different from us because we want to
punish those who don't look or act like us this
guy's a flame bird watcher ironically yeah it's
our turn Metropolis so please turn off your
power shut off your buildings Breakers your
generators yes Superman has saved this city over
and over again it's time for us to save Superman
yeah who's got you yeah Spider-Man too
come on Superman turn off the light
trigger the inside it's gonna work
dude your whole skill set is cheating I won't
let you hurt the people of this city yeah
oh dude I just want to strangle this guy you
chose to be a monster Ivo then what does that mean
cool pull him out pull them
out don't you read the paper oh
oh damn cool nice I'm Superman
yeah it's Dustin done and dusted out of this world
get used to me being right here because
I am never letting you go again buddy
oh
The Daily Planet
he's Lex Luthor yeah so don't ever worry me
like that again Smallville I love you and
all these cuties
I ship them yeah look at that wing beautiful
no oh no no James our superiors have been
displeased at your failure to take lethal
Action Against The Invader at the cost of Civilian
lives and what do you call what happened today the
your [__] you are no longer head of task
force Acts I am whoa from now on we're taking a
different track in regards to Superman ivo's last
invention the Omega cannon good should weaken the
alien enough for you to carry out your new Mission
track down and terminate Superman ugh how cruel
jeepers I wonder if that's gonna be the finale
it could be I mean yeah it seems like and then
maybe that's where the truth who is he of you get
Alex who's that guy yeah do we see bibo in person
do we get to that I mean that really matters
do they eat a bevos that's the post credits
last picture on the credits will be them eating
yeah the Polaroid is of bippos they zoom out
shows great yeah all right rolling in
the episode the finale here we go finale
so good so far this sticks The Landing
the whole ranking of the DC yeah we gotta throw it
in there somewhere it's our first show that's full
oh no
oh
effectively ominous yeah it's a
super nightmare post-traumatic
Superman disorder this s stands for sad
oh no no no no no no if I'll have that
nightmare but as a Kryptonian yeah I'll
never be like you and if you come to Earth
again I'll be here to stop you about that
oh
damn they got me I didn't think we're
getting English they got me I'm like is
it reacting to to Clark's language
acclimate I do wonder if we get a
season two if we get more Krypton okay
good season two I would love a season
two thank you so much for hosting me and my
dad for Thanksgiving I'm bringing yams this
year it's gonna be yam-tastic it might be
Lane let's do it I think it's General Lane
a statue of parasite I need your help finding
the general the guy who kidnapped and then
tried to kill you your father yeah you're
sure he hasn't seen the terrifying evil
Superman data sphere no I'm seeing that it would
destroy him just hate secrets we said no words
characters are always saying that you three have
brought me more trouble than every other intern
we've ever had know how we deal with this
type of behavior The Daily Planet whippings
City safe Superman by Lois Lane Clark Kenton Jimmy
so the only thing to do was to make a reporter
yes oh that was fair that's Barry
White there you go that's beautiful
you guys are the new Team Rocket cute
cute cute it's true she gets Pulitzer
oh I love this Lane go have a Happy Thanksgiving
good I need you to stay awesome we need to talk
about flame bird I want to put it on The Daily
Planet YouTube channel I need those views well
you know that Clark's the one who saved the city
and he couldn't have done it without you Clark
peel potatoes I'm in the turkey Zone you unlock
this door with the baster of imagination pocket
after his powers showed up Clark was
so scared of hurting someone that
himself at a distance but now he has you with
him thank you for helping us avoid a bright burn
single-handed lead now irresponsible so I hope
you love them Dad's here reporting for Duty come
on what's the Worst That Could Happen he's rude to
you and Ma and PAW and then everybody hates me hey
nothing can change the way I feel about
you not even your dad who tried to kill me
my dad
nice to meet you Mr Lane please
call me General Lane oh boy
have we met before nope just have one of
those faces how do you spend your time
jeez she's smart hard-working and successful she's
Elaine it's what we expect I am not oppressed what
are you doing with your life Kent Clark does a lot
just the other day he saved the entire store whoa
at the store ma we should help in the kitchen
no do not leave be right back Mom let's say
you had an enemy I'd turn him into a friend but
if someone really hated you you can't hate your
girlfriend's father Clark oh boy no matter what
he says about your perfect son go throw hands mom
Sean will Martha means Mrs Kent said something
about success I had my first article published
ta-da already made the ball fan of Superman
everyone loves him not everyone you haven't
read it have you I've been busy I can't read I'm
trying to kill Superman I wish I could remember
where I've seen you before applied sciences just
a journalism degree sir do you always wear glasses
Lois's dad is the general the
general who tried to kill me what
I love this I hate Lois she is as
sweet as apple pie but that man is
a lot sure what a great final episode after
the action he gets dip it's like this level
don't tell anyone Jimmy but this turkey is
refusing to come to temp Jimmy's got the
solution flame bird knows oh everyone you have
something to tell me I don't know who you are
how about awkward this all is Clark
you are going to tell Lois about her
dad then you are both going to thank
me for my emotional maturity and for
bringing your stuff which
you laughed at the planet
now no no what is this they waste
no time this show just moves yeah
this isn't you I can't
oh
no oh
no this is bad what's going on the rock
looks so freaking painful
oh no oh no no no day Zero is back at all
of his trauma oh my God we are standing at
Ground Zero of an alien invasion Dad how
do you know about this I need you all to
evacuate now playing here deploy
all out he's I have to make sure
everyone gets away before I deal with
the ship how are you gonna do that it's
it's oh it's literally his crib
I think Scott Glenn would make a
good Paul Kent oh even though he's been
like a billion comic things now plastic
training in warmth
Louis oh no I like it like a
good corn maze yeah exactly hey
what oh wow that's effective from
a tiny shirt from a distance yeah
thank you
oh jeez man not bad it's you you're
the general task force x oh Nemesis
Omega zero day next article oh those
words why did you say those words
Lois there's so much more to this
truly
wowie the rock that hurts
Clark hurts the robots too
oh no oh no damn this is what happened on
zero day that rock is the only thing that
can destroy my ship and close the portal it'll
kill you Clark I love you and I can't lose you oh
you too
dude
sheeps
and again with that like lensing effect
yeah and the escalation of stakes wow
get out of there
still going at him whoa
oh boy Whoa hello
cool yes
well Kell team up yeah God when's
he gonna actually like know his name
wow that looks painful oh
God yeah
there that is what is happening to the
Earth's like axis right now is all these
things crash into it just another statue next
to the parasite statue tell him my son oh
shot back to Earth all over again yep same cradle
corn feels jacked up
be the hero man
I need you to get out of the way Lois so you
can murder the man who just saved us I am doing
this to protect you Lois that man risked
everything to protect our world let him go
General what's your situation I'm dead false alarm
Dad thank you I oh Batman he definitely knows
that's Clark now right is he pretty close
pretty much recognizing before bringing leverage's
parents now and all this still not to Temp Clark
great dinner is served I almost didn't
think we would get to dinner you said you
had something to share I sold flame her to the
Daily Planet for 5.6 million dollars what what
the amps please I'm rich now pass me my
damn yams oh that's so good oh oh yeah
unexpected
whoa getting those dark side they have
destroyed our ships and closed our portals
before dark side I assume oh interesting ha I
think I got so many questions here what a big
show this is yeah man it's a thick boy next season
Jimmy's rich oh out of nowhere which is something
that does happen he does come into lots of money
sometimes in the comics which is always funny
really oh yeah this Rich history that like Rivals
the Luthers for like the Olsen's coming out of the
money and they lose it the Luther's like there's
like a rivalry if anything else to the Luthers
I love that I I think I mean I'm not an expert
by any stretch but I love this Jimmy I I really
I still think that Alex's legs I think that's
probably that's got to be likely and I'm glad it
didn't happen here but I think the fact that they
interviewed him and they showed him in the last
episode like sulking they cut to him like watching
the live stream yeah and he's wearing purple yeah
likes Luther's color that's true red hair yeah
historically Lex Luthor's hair before he loses his
hair they're gonna let him keep the hair for like
three seasons they'll get a beard like John uh
what's his name from two men and a baby or What's
that show oh prior John Craig Two and a Half Men
two and a half good men yeah it's like two men and
a baby a half man yeah maybe yeah that's the show
he played Lex with a beer um I enjoyed the hell
out of the show it's very good yeah I love this I
I this was like the joy of this this really felt
to me again in my more limited experience like
a compendium of a run where like you have very
much issues but they all amount to something
which is why they got compounded into this one
unit and yeah there's plenty more to come you
could dip in at any point and enjoy that one
episode but you know there are you know you
got your two-part event episodes like yeah it's
got a little bit of everything that feels like a
comic it's appropriately anime in a way that I
think is really nice and fun and allows again
for the familial aspects of both anime manga by
extension and comic books yeah uh here you know
it kind of celebrates all those things in a way
that uh coalesces in a really nice fashion and
then two it's just like a well-told story yeah
I completely agree with your assessment of the
the trade paperback feel because it definitely
feels like two trades that are like a part one
and part two that first half we watched kind of
felt like episodes one through four were one thing
yeah and that felt like a trade that was like you
know those issues like you said that build to one
Arc but then the second half which was like five
six seven eight nine and ten felt like another
Arc that did go together well but you could just
grab an issue and I really like that the tropes
they use from the comics were very approachable
and the anime tropes I was a little worried would
get less approachable um like when they did the
rocket power stuff like that's about as like big
as I as I like sometimes like animated shows get
too big and it feels like a fox oh yeah and like
the The Sweat Beads that anime do and then they
like fall over like this and The Sweat Beads but
it was for like moments of tension they never
had like like it walked a very fine line that I
liked they did Super restrict because it's like I
can think of at least in these couple these three
episodes we watched today there's that bit with
Vicki Vale where they put in like the vignetted
soft focus like that's kind of an anime thing or
or here I think at one point when they're about
to get uh when Perry's about to show them their
yep front page you know they've got the shoulder
squiggle yeah it's like it's they borrowed
yeah they worked those cartoonish stylized
anime tropes or flourishes but yeah in like the
most restrained way possible like it's it's just
sort of the art style and again like some of
the approach to especially like backgrounds
and things yeah you'll have like metropolis and
it's like you'll have this one layer that's very
detailed and then there's one minute and the
villains were definitely anime yeah yeah yeah
and I think in a way that that works but that felt
more like an anime or again like like metal gear
which is yeah like you know a lot of Japanese
sci-fi fiction uh and so yeah I I liked having
that metal gear aspect though and I think too I I
can imagine it being something that people might
debate about like I feel like that's a choice they
made here which is you're gonna have a bunch of
uh you know one-off villains who eventually will
have to team up under the guise of task force x
I thought that was very conscientious and even
though I'm sure it's not everybody's favorite
thing I liked what they're going for with okay
here's all this disparate Kryptonian Tech and
we don't quite fully understand it and each of
these guys now has a different ability because
of that and it seems like interaction with these
devices rubs off on everybody um so you know while
it's like you have um is that black canary you
know doing the shriek and like that's not like
an organic thing and I get why some people oh she
was siren here though yeah yeah siren um you know
it's like I can understand people not maybe loving
that that's you know a tech based thing but for
what they're doing here and for the themes and
everything and because it is Superman I thought
that was kind of a neat and appropriate way to
tie that all together here especially because
this show doesn't feel burdened yet by having to
share with others which I really enjoyed yeah I
cut you off though are we saying about the middle
distance because I I didn't lose my anime train I
thought with the villains but uh the animation
style foreground oh yeah you'll have like this
really detailed like when he flies up over the
city you know it's like you'll have this detailed
foreground and then this kind of middle detail uh
layer oh and then in the back it's just kind of
like white and and you know outlines and stuff
like that and things like that I think are are
again more toward the stylization of an anime and
when uh Clark was was trapped in like the keeping
his face vague they like let the sadness just be
shapes which I liked it but that was a really good
way to show motion uh I like the characterization
a lot uh Lois her lack of journalistic skill
really worked once they explained the Multiverse
because I was like really bothered by like they're
already working on the planet but like this is
not the lowest I know and I really think that
made the whole show grow on me I think this is
one of the better use of multiverses because not
only did it improve the show's rules it does keep
things separate and I'm then not comparing it to
like well that's not what happens that's not like
this is the character it gives me this beautiful
carte blanche to just like enjoy the thing so
I think it does a really good job what you need
in an else world is the heart of the character
whether it's subverting that heart or nailing
it this Nails it like I love your homelander and
your Omni man and I've talked to Ad nauseam about
how park has to be good so those characters
can exist this gets Clark so you feel none
of his his decisions feel dumb he's not a dumb
character and a lot of people think that being
nice is being dumb or being kind is being dumb
and that's why Clark's important like the reasons
and that's why Superman is so important is
because being kind is hard and we should look
to that as a strength that someone can be kind
instead of seeing it as a weakness I think a lot
of these fans of Superman that see kindness as a
weakness don't understand the difficulty and the
importance of kindness and they don't understand
what Superman is and this show inherently gets
Superman more than 90 of the things I've seen of
him adapted to other mediums I was so impressed
so many lines of dialogue obviously a lot of his
actions a lot of his decisions but they maintained
this beautiful childlike wonder that never felt
dumb they maintained this beautiful kindness that
never felt like he was naive and the naivete that
he did have was earned by Youth and midwesternness
not dumbness yeah so impressed yeah no absolutely
I'm not saying Midwestern people are dumb don't
come at me Midwest I'm saying the kindness that
comes from living in the town versus the city
like there's a there's an awareness of City Life
versus Town life there's no preference there I
just don't want the certain towns to come at me
I love no shade to nobody but nobody but yeah no
he and I think they nicely embody his his Journey
as a character like beyond all the Superman stuff
he's still just a guy trying to make it in
the big city with his buds and crushing on
a girl yeah and and Crush was great yeah and
coming of age and going through changes and
finding out about your pet like there are lots of
layers and things like that that you could apply
to various real life moments for people and I
think uh yeah like they never ever lost sight
of the heart while still maintaining all of the
action and stuff that you want and I mean like
you know for I'm curious as to how the medium of
Animation is going to continue to grow and warp
in our current day and age this part of me wonders
during like I thought they did a really nice job
with the action and I thought they did a really
nice job overall gripping with those things part
of me wonders having seen some other anime like
wow what would some of these fights look like if
they had like demon Slayers or something like
that but but I never miss those things or even
moments where you're like ah you know this scene
they're not doing as much like mouth movement sure
um but like this the the style and the approach
and and the spirit that they're able to conjure
and the fact too like I like in storytelling
like this I think too because it's been so well
trodden and we know so many of the tropes uh when
they really get right to the heart of a conflict
or when they establish a conflict they go for
it they don't yeah like ah This is Gonna Come
Back nope it's happening yeah and it's like you
know we pulled the Band-Aid off of her learning
his secret identity we pulled the Band-Aid off of
um of uh the Multiverse we pull the Band-Aid off
of all this stuff at the end with him meeting
Sam and confronting all these circumstances
and I'm really serious in the last episode to be
that big I thought it'd be like a day new mall
because I thought we'd have like the parasite
episode and then like that'd be our big action
then the last episode would be like and now we
find out some peace and then we go to the next
season like instead it was like we gotta have
this conflict and it was a great tease because
you have the the prospect of Thanksgiving dinner
you think well we're gonna do something more Slice
of Life more tense at home you know more tensile
grounded scale more Clark and then yeah yeah the
Superman as so often happens with these characters
intervenes on that and there's no choice but to
go do that stuff and I thought the way that they
wrapped all that around and then finally came back
to dinner was really nice and and yeah you've
got a solid Conflict for Lois you called Sam
from the jump Sam Lane that was great that was
a good call and it was a I I enjoyed the build
I thought he was right about seven tenths the way
in and I was holding on to Deadshot uh but yeah I
really really like this too I just thought it'd
be interesting to have like a guy that's like a
guy and like then you're like whoa It's a guy that
I know like he's especially when they give him the
gun I was like what if he's really good shot yeah
but I really like the sampling twist because then
it's the Norman Osborne thing it's the it's
the uh Adrian tombs in Spider-Man the new one
um I really enjoyed this this Show's great
uh definitely in my upper tier of the DC
animated stuff which is saying a lot we
joked earlier like they really don't miss
um even the lower DC stuff is better than a
lot of stuff it's very good and very loyal
and these writers should perhaps work on them
again man like ever the writers the direct like
the creators what James gun's doing I just want
him to watch this and also to be like well we're
building this whole universe live actually maybe
you guys bring some of this stuff because this
is Superman absolutely was absolutely is what did
you think reject Nation I enjoyed the hell out of
it hopefully and you enjoyed the heck out of it
because Superman wouldn't say hell he's a golly
gee swell boy uh please leave a comment below
let us know what you thought of this experience
let us know what you want us to dive into next we
see you Young Justice fans we see you and it is a
maybe uh keep an eye out for what we dive into
next hit that notification Bell hit that comment
bar hit that validation thumb and hit that
hug your family don't hit him hug them hug
them hug them hit the Instinct hit that hit that
hit that uh that notification Bell of love and
have some Thanksgiving we're almost in the fall
we are it's Halloween in stores already I went
to Target today and it was very Halloweenish
they were moving stuff around yeah by the way
it's almost September one no more it's like it's
Halloween no more two weeks when September turns
into October and then Christmas what if August
is still 100 degrees but candy is melting in
the aisles bring it in I talked to the lady
at Michael's last year I was like when's Peak
Halloween and she's like in August because we
gotta get the [__] out of here during October
I was like ah it makes sense but literally going
to Halloween I got like a a preview night for a
haunted house on the 7th of September not even
October in a week I'm getting spooky yeah I've
already got three of my costumes figured out
fall doesn't start to the 21st of September not
I'm always doing it last second
I got three I got three good in
the comments let me know what you guys
are being for Halloween we love spooky
season here get after it's your
lovelies we'll see you next time
foreign